[Musique]
m
alors je vais vous parler de mon
histoire et de mon école donc j'ai fait
de mon corps mon école quand j'étais
petit mon premier ma première expérience
à l'école ça a été la crèche comme
pratiquement tout le monde et j'ai fugué
et la suite été dans la même dans la
même dynamique c'est à dire j'ai
beaucoup fumé je préférais aller jouer
dehors grimper aux arbres
c'était ça mon école petit donc comme
vous le comprenez j'ai pas été à l'école
très longtemps mais petit j'ai commencé
très tôt la gymnastique artistique à 6
ans j'étais petits gymnastes et on a un
fort mais mon corps à la gymnastique et
irait donc très vite à 10 ans j'avais
une musculature assez impressionnante
puis j'ai dû quitter ma ville et
c'était dans un autre à la campagne qui
avait pas de cours de gymnastique et
j'ai commencé assez tôt la danse parce
que des copines m'avait dit viens c'est
bien et tout alors je dis ok pourquoi
pas j'ai commencé la danse et la preuve
de danse ou d'un an m'a dit écoute tu as
un corps fait pour la danse est ce que
tu veux devenir professionnel donc j'ai
dit ben je me dis réfléchit bien parce
que j'ai dit ok donc elle m'a dit ok je
te prends je te forme gratuitement et
tu vas devenir danseur professionnel
donc pendant quatre ans j'ai suivi son
enseignement et au bout de quatre ans
elle m'a dit mme eva temps maintenant
c'est fini tu es forme et donc à 17 ans
je me suis retrouvé dans une compagnie
professionnelle et j'ai commencé à
travailler avec des adultes
c'était 17 ans on a encore adolescent et
donc j'ai appris à travers mon corps à
travers la danse l'école dollar ça veut
dire quand on fait de la danse ben on va
s'intéresser à la musique parce que la
musique elle est intrinsèquement
intrinsèquement liées à la danse
donc on apprend tout c'est vrai les
différentes musiques sur l'histoire de
l'art
on s'intéresse à la peinture parce que
les peintres ont toujours admiré la
danse et peint la danse
donc je me suis formé artistiquement à
travers la danse en dehors évidemment de
la discipline que ça nécessite la danse
ensuite je suis allé à paris et j'ai
commencé à travailler dans d'autres
compagnies et j'ai commencé aussi à
travailler les arts martiaux donc une
autre formation du corps une autre
philosophie du corps une autre
philosophie très oriental qui où j'ai
appris à lier le corps et l'esprit à
faire une espèce d'unité entre le corps
et l'esprit
ça ça m'a beaucoup aidé dans à la fois
dans ma vie personnelle et dans le
travail purement physique donc après ça
j'ai j'étais dans la danse g g
fait des chorégraphies ce qui paraît la
suite logique d'un parcours de danseur
et puis au bout de quelques années je
n'arrivais pas à trouver le langage qui
m'intéressait à transmettre aux gens
donc je me dis mais je suis limité par
par la scène je suis limité par ce
rapport frontal je suis limité je me
sentais étriqué
donc j'ai décidé de tout de tout faire
balader j'étais directeur de théâtre je
me suis intéressé à la technique faire
de l'éclairage enfin nous diverses
choses et un jour je me suis dit bon
qu'est-ce qui me
qu'est ce qui pourrait me faire plaisir
qu'est-ce qui pourrait vraiment me faire
grandir est réellement réussir à
exprimer ce que j'avais en moi donc j'ai
tout arrêté de nouveau et je me suis
j'ai pris deux ans pour préparer une
performance qui s'appelle à l'époque qui
s'appelait bleus pros victoire c'était
en 2001 ça c'est une reprise que j'ai
fait en 2007
donc voilà je me suis dit le mouvement
j'ai du mal avec le mouvement j'arrive
pas c'était tellement exploiter le
mouvement que je me suis dit j'ai pas ma
place ici donc j'ai dit je vais
travailler sur l'immobilité montré
qu'elles étaient les mouvements
possibles à partir de l'immobilité et
qu'est-ce qui pouvait exister comme
mouvement quand on était immobile donc
j'ai fait
cette expérience donc je suis dans une
boîte en plexiglas immobile et petit à
petit je commence à pleurer bleus à ma
mort qui coule du néo bleu
je commence à bavay bleus je commence à
transpirer bleus tout ça dans une
extrême lenteur et pour moi ça va
plusieurs significations
donc il y avait ce mouvement de
l'intérieur du corps vers l'extérieur du
corps et j'avais envie de le montrer à
travers quoi je les montrer à travers
des choses que normalement on ne montre
pas les larmes
socialement c'est pas très bien vu de
montrer ses larmes de montrer la morve
de montrer la bave de montrer la
transpiration donc quelque part j'ai
voulu sublimer ces choses qu'on cache et
que je vois pas pourquoi elle ne serait
pas belle donc
c'est peut-être monstrueux mais ces
monstrueuses mambo donc voilà ça c'est
la fin du processus où je transpire donc
ça ça a été vraiment j'ai mis deux ans à
préparer cette performance c'est un
énorme travail avec en lien avec des
médecins de la biochimie beaucoup de
procéder beaucoup d'essais beaucoup de
tests parce que c'est des choses qu'ils
n'ont jamais été faites donc voila mais
la chose principale qui m'intéressait
c'était de trouver un langage poétique
avec le corps voilà ça c'est une donc
j'ai fait énormément de performance j'ai
essayé d'explorer les limites physiques
et mentales du corps donc jusqu'où un
corps peut aller sans se faire mal et en
toute conscience
donc là j'ai fait une expérience qui qui
n'a rien à voir avec un exploit je veux
pas être dans le livre des guinness je
le fais vraiment comme une expérience
intérieure
donc ça cette performance pour moi elle
symbolise vraiment une expérience
intérieure
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on est
recouvert de 600 kg de verre brisé
fraîchement brise et donc qui est
potentiellement extrêmement dangereux et
comment on peut sortir de ça de manière
totalement inde m
c'est
c'est un long processus donc là je sors
en deux heures deux heures de temps je
vais sortir extrêmement lentement donc
c'est tout un travail sur la lenteur
c'est aussi une manière de dire quelque
part je fais du slow art joffre du temps
aux gens j'offre du temps geof la
possibilité aux gens de se poser et
d'oublier absolument tous deux du monde
dans lequel ils vivent
parce que c'est tellement l'image est
tellement puissante en réalité quand on
la voit que ça provoque des ça peut
provoquer des d'échec des chocs
émotionnels donc la dernière fois il ya
deux semaines j'étais en pologne
donc au moment où je sortais de la
baignoire et que j'ai croisé son regard
elle s'était effondrée mais en hurlant
elle a fait une régression elle a pleuré
comme un bébé mais d'une telle violence
et ça ne s'arrêtait pas que tout le
public était en état de choc
j'ai dû sortir de l'avesnois j'ai dû la
prendre dans mes bras pour pour qu'elle
se calme sinon on l'emmenait l'hôpital
psychiatrique
donc il ya quelque chose de 2,2 direct
de très forts qui se passe pendant les
performances et ça c'est aussi une chose
qui m'intéresse le lien qui peut exister
ce lien avec le avec le corps je parle
pas c'est qu'une image donc
voilà je le fais en chine pour les gens
en chine il pleure aussi pour d'autres
raisons
ils le voient pas personnellement il le
voit comme une oppression l'oppression
de letat l'oppression sociale qui est
très forte en chine
donc pour eux ça leur parle énormément
et en même temps je ne suis pas là à
dire je suis content la pression je suis
c'est ouvert l'interprétation est
toujours ouverte
ça c'est ça qui m'intéresse donc à
travers tout ça moi ce score c'est
toujours mon école c'est à dire
j'apprends j'apprends mon corps
j'apprends le monde à travers cette
position ça dort dans cette position je
peux centre sentir réellement
physiquement qu'est ce que c'est
l'oppression
imaginez une demie voiture qui vous
tombe dessus
1 1 quelqu'un qui fait de l'apnée me dis
ce que tu vilain c'est la même chose que
ce que je vis à 100 mètres de profondeur
dans l'océan
donc qui a quelque chose de très
puissant qui se passe il ya une chose
aussi que je trouve intéressant de
parler c'est le rapport à la douleur ça
veut dire je ne suis pas on voit jamais
mon visage empreint de bouleurs ou dans
la souffrance
je suis absolument très calme quand je
sors de la baignoire ce qui est sans
blessure donc les gens sont toujours
étonnés mais il ya un truc qui un truc
n'y a pas de truc quand je prépare le
verger le casse je me coupe comme tout
le monde mais à partir du moment où je
me prépare je me concentre je peux
prendre le verre me laver avec je vais
pas me couper
donc ça c'est j'ai pas de réponse à part
que voilà j'ai une préparation physique
intense j'ai une préparation mentale
intense
je médite je fais des exercices de
respiration toussaint tous
essentiellement fait que je suis capable
de vivre ça sans douleur et ça c'est
important
mais la douleur je la sens à un moment
donné simplement je la traverse
donc il y à un point très fort sur
lequel j'insiste toujours de dire mais
la douleur elle est importante il faut
pas ni les la douleur il faut pas j'ai
l'impression que nos sociétés ont volé
notre sens de la le sens du mot douleur
la médecine a complètement déformé le
sens de ce mot donc je suis très en
colère sur toute la réappropriation des
mots que nos sociétés sont en train de
construire
on nous vole le mot performance même est
complètement dénaturé aujourd'hui je
suis performant je fais de la
performance
ça vient d'une tradition assez ancienne
depuis l'es2 puis le mouvement dada
jusque dans les années 70 on appelait sa
performance et avec un mot maintenant
ses performances sociales ses
performances économiques ses
performances ceci cela tout et devient
performance moi ça me ça me laisse très
perplexe donc de deux de voler les mots
voilà la douleur elle est là un réel
sens c'est vraiment un point indicateurs
de où on en est par rapport à une chose
qu'est ce qui nous fait en douleur
c'étaient des informations importantes
la douleur c'est une information
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit cette
information donc c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
voilà là on est dans la suspension donc
suspendu à ces eaux là c'est une vue
depuis le dessous
donc c'est une vue avec des
fils de nylon donc je suis suspendu avec
des fils de nylon donc c'est extrêmement
coupant je pense qu'au bout de quatre
heures je reste une heure là ça commence
déjà à me couper la peau donc j'ose pas
imaginer au bout de six heures la peau à
l'aide traverser et qu'au bout de huit
heures
ça commence à scier les eaux pourquoi
pourquoi je me mets dans ces états là où
dans des situations comme ça je me dis
après avoir vécu ça je peux tout vivre
je peux absolument tout vivre et je ne
ressens pas la douleur comme tout le
monde
peut-être il ya aussi l'idée du danger
si les fils il ya un fil qui se casse il
y en a 20 s'il en manque un je tombe et
je m'écrase donc il ya toujours ce
danger de la mort qui me qui m'intéresse
énormément cette frontière entre la vie
et la mort en parlant de frontières j'ai
fait une performance qui s'appelle
rideau qui est très actuel par rapport à
l'immigration
donc mon discours il était assez simple
c'est que les frontières elle tue et je
voulais un peu d'imagés ça donc le
rideau il est fait avec des hauts et des
lames de rasoir et pendant quatre heures
le riz dont il me couvre et il remonte
et les lames de rasoir évidemment m elle
passe sur moi
elle me coupe en deux donc il ya quelque
chose de 2,2 lors de l'absurdité des
frontières voilà c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les gens dans
toutes mes performances j'ai un peu
cassé le rapport qui a la dent des
performantes les gens ils feraient tout
autour de moi est vraiment très proche
où on peut me toucher on peut j'aime
cette abolition des frontières et donc
là déjà pour moi c'est déjà une
frontière et j'aime bien dans la
performance telle que je la conçois
avoir les gens très près qu'ils puissent
vivre la performance avec moi c'est se
trouve essentiel de partager une
expérience c'est pas moi je me montre
ses ont créé ensemble une ont créé
ensemble une performance qui qui peut
changer énormément il ya des fois des
gens qui interviennent beaucoup la
performance elle et elle devient autre
chose
et pour moi il n'y a pas de problème
elle évolue quelqu'un va peut-être se
mettre couché à côté de moi peut-être
quelqu'un va se mettre nu à côté de moi
donc tout ça ça va transformer la
performance ça ça m'intéresse aussi
c'est qui est pas une fixité de ce que
je propose mais que c'est tout ça reste
toujours vivant
voilà ça c'est une performance beaucoup
plus soft
j'ai un costume blanc mais ce pas et je
me promène dans la rue et je vous ma
petite mallette et sur la mallette il ya
une question qui est posée avec un stylo
et ses marques et comment voudriez vous
mourir et écrivez votre votre réponse
sur mon costume donc tout d'un coup les
gens au début quand ils me voient ils
rigolent et puis quand ils lisent la
question et qu'ils comprennent qu'il
faut qu'ils pensent à leur mort et qui
doivent écrire sur moi avoir un contact
c'est passionnant même s'il n'y a pas de
défi physique mais il ya un rapport
humain qui qui s'installe et pour moi
finalement le principal c'est que ce
contact humain reste de plus en plus
vivant et que le corps il est au centre
de ce mouvement
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]